So months ago, I told you that the White House
and Donald Trump are trying to normalize Corona
virus deaths so that they're just not notable
anymore.
Yeah, people are dying.
People are dying from Corona virus every day.
But we're sort of moving on.
And this is hard to pinpoint exactly when
it started.
But certainly it was a very clear decision
that was made when Donald Trump wondered aloud
about injecting bleach and isopropyl alcohol
to treat Corona virus.
That was where it was like very clear.
These are really doing much more damage, these
press briefings, than they are helping anybody
in the Trump administration.
And so they stop the daily press briefings
and they essentially considered that they
had defeated the invisible enemy, or as Donald
Trump often calls it, the invisible scorch.
Trump stopped talking about it, talked exclusively
about the stock market reopening, how we've
won, and there's therapeutics and vaccines
on the way.
We stopped seeing doctors, Foushee and Berk's
on any kind of regular basis.
And Trump increasingly distanced himself from
the even medical claims that Dr. Foushee would
make.
And one of the themes of the Trump administration,
bigger picture has been hyper normalization.
And that's exactly what they're trying to
do with corona virus.
Hyper normalization is the making normal of
things that should not be seen as normal,
including the weekly or near daily scandals
that we've seen during this administration,
the way in which Trump talks to people and
uses xenophobic and racist dog whistles and
has made fun of and bullied just about everybody.
And I've admitted that even for me, because
I'm in this stuff and covering this stuff
every day, I have to go out of my way to remind
myself, even though 20 of these things happened
this week, none of them is normal.
If any one of these things had happened during
Barack Obama's presidency, they would be one
week scandals on Fox News.
That gets us to the new reports coming out
of the White House.
And these are reports from people close to
the Trump campaign and the Trump administration.
The new goal is and
it's of course, we knew this, they want to
reframe the corona virus.
They want to make the exploding number of
cases and also the four now lower, but still
significant number of deaths.
The new normal make people numb to the numbers.
If you hear that 400 people died every day.
Eventually it sort of becomes I hate to use
this analogy like kids dying of hunger in
Africa.
Right.
Eventually, it becomes not about the individuals.
It becomes a number.
And we're sort of used to the number.
There's gun violence and people die from from
gun, from gun violence.
And we're not going to stop selling people
guns as the gun people have said.
And people kids are dying of hunger in Africa
every day.
But we're still going to continue to throw
out 30 percent of our food or whatever it
is.
Right.
As the phrase
is, a phrase often goes and, you know, 400
people died of corona virus, but we're essentially
numb to it is the goal from the Trump administration.
And there's a reason that Donald Trump talks
about it less and less other than to claim
victory, which is his campaign realizes that
Corona virus is a loser of a topic for him.
This is one of the reasons why his approval
rating has imploded, his handling of the virus,
the associated economic handling, and recently
the reaction to the protests against police
brutality.
So the focus will continue to be economic
recovery, jobs, CEOs, fast food restaurants
opening and make the cases and deaths.
The new normal.
We can live with the virus.
Schools should reopen.
That's a focus now.
There should be professional sports.
We'll have a vaccine any day now.
Everybody should just keep doing more and
more stuff.
Even if the case numbers keep increasing,
even if we're hitting weekly new case records
a week in and week out.
And if we end up with an escalating death
toll that some expect in the next month, I'm
going to have a bigger report tomorrow about
the increase in cases without yet an increase
in deaths.
But we may still get that in the next month.
Hopefully we won't.
But the Trump administration idea is if we
stop talking about it, if we stop highlighting
it, maybe Trump's.
Base will at least move on and maybe the media
will start to move on.
The idea is the public will accept 50000 cases
a day, maybe even 100000 cases a day if the
numbers go in that direction, because eventually
there will be a vaccine and a treatment.
People will become numb to the numbers and
we've got to keep
the economy open.
So my message to you is we can't let them
make that this story right.
Trump has failed hugely on the virus.
They are doing this.
They're trying to normalize the rapid spread
of the virus because they recognize that the
virus could be what removes Donald Trump from
office in the November election.
Trump's approval rating on dealing with Corona
virus is in the toilet.
Voters overwhelmingly prefer Joe Biden to
Trump in terms of who would would Biden better
deal with Corona virus than Trump has?
If we could identify the one moment where
it really went bad, I keep going back to what
about if we hit the body with isopropyl alcohol
and bleach and then from there it's been very
much downhill.
And if the numbers don't turn around.
The only choice they have is let's normalize
it.
Let's make people numb to
Let's make believe that this is just normal.
And notice that we talk about that phrase.
An ounce of prevention is cheaper than a pound
of cure.
Simply dealing with the virus properly from
day one would have been both much simpler
and much less costly in terms of money and
lives than now trying to lie to people to
get them to vote for you.
We would have saved lives.
We would have almost seen a guaranteed Trump
reelection if Trump had handled it well.
If Trump had actually dealt with Corona virus
starting on January 20th.
Remember, South Korea got their first case
on January 20th.
So did we.
Maybe because of the time difference.
It was the 19th and the 20th, but within hours
of each other, South Korea and the US got
our first cases.
The US had low testing and high spread.
Whereas South
Korea immediately developed test contact,
traced isolated people.
We could have had high testing, lower spread,
fewer cases, fewer deaths.
And it would be really tough for Joe Biden
right now.
If Trump had demonstrated leadership by really
dealing with the virus, I don't know that
Biden's polling plus 12 nationally, if that's
the case.
Prevention is cheaper than cure.
Avoiding the situation, getting so bad to
begin with would have been way easier than
now, trying to fix it.
And when I say fix it, I mean both electorally
and in terms of the virus.
If you look at Florida, Texas and Arizona,
it's essentially out of control.
You're looking now at months to reduce those
case numbers, just like it took that long
in Massachusetts and in New York and in other
places.
So just a reminder, in 2014, when two Americans
died of Ebola.
Republicans were demanding
Obama's head on a stick.
We now have over one hundred and thirty thousand
deaths in the United States.
And the Trump strategy is normalize it and
pretend that that's just the way things have
to be.
And I cannot skip this important piece.
Sorry I hit my might because I'm getting so
wound up.
This goes back to the failures of the educational
system in the US and the cultural failures
as well, especially among the right when it
comes to anti intellectual ism.
If you know even a little bit more about medicine,
science, statistics, critical thinking, epistemology,
media literacy, a ton of the disinformation
that spreads about the virus would never spread.
Some of it would, but a lot less of it would
spread.
If you are slightly more educated, you don't
fall for record.
Job creation in June, four point eight million
jobs.
If you're slightly
more educated, you realize.
Wait a second.
We lost 47 million jobs.
We got four point eight million back.
We're really in bad shape.
What the hell is Trump talking about?
But unfortunately, people do fall for it.
So part of this is education.
Part of it is you have a willing audience
that wants to repeat anything that Trump says
for political reasons.
And that's where we end up today.
Now, very, very last thing.
Even if Americans grow numb to the cases and
the deaths, I don't know that they will grow
numb to being evicted.
I don't know that they will grow numb to not
having money to pay their bills or to not
having a job.
So that is something that will be tougher
to normalize for the Trump administration.
We'll just
have
to see how it goes.